the yo Cancer Center recently received
notification
national cancer so that we've been
an NCI designated Comprehensive Cancer
Center that's extraordinarily important
to Yale and to our patients
comprehensive means that you have
patient care and research in a broad
number of areas all the way from cancer
prevention and control which means what
predisposes us to getting cancer how do
our dietary and help activities leave or
predisposes to getting cancer to basic
cancer research meaning work which is
designed to look at the fundamental
causes of cancer to cellular a molecular
level and then finally cancer treatment
and clinical research where we take the
we take the science and we turn into new
treatments for patients and that
comprehensiveness is something which is
incredibly important for us as a Cancer
Center cancer research is something
which is incredibly exciting any at
times something still humbling for us I
get asked often how close are we to
curing cancer has the Human Genome
Project yielded results that bring us
closer to curing cancer what I would say
is is that we're right now at the cusp
of being able to use the tools of the
Human Genome Project the tools that
allow us to sequence genes to get us
closer to being able to treat cancer I
do believe that cancer will be cured
whether that's in 10 years or 50 years
I'm not certain but I believe me now the
path to think about how we're going to
get there it's going to come from
understand your genetic makeup of an
individual cancer and understand the
genetic makeup of a patient and how
those two factors interact also at the
Yale Cancer Center we have a terrific
amount of work looking at the immune
system and how the immune system can be
used to fight cancers this year for the
first time we've seen results of suggest
that the buys a new system can be turned
on specifically to fight melanomas lung
cancers kidney cancers cancers in the
genitourinary system and so the idea
that the body's immune system can be
used in concert with drugs that target
genetic abnormality within cancers makes
me think that we're going to be able to
extend survival from cancer clinical
miles are the heart of what we need to
be doing as a comprehensive cancer
center if you look globally in the
United States there'll be more than five
hundred thousand deaths from cancer this
year they'll be more than 1.5 million
people were diagnosed with cancer this
year yet less than 1% of both of those
groups will participate in cancer
clinical trials we are not doing well
enough in treating cancer to have that
number be that low I believe that number
needs to be closer to twenty percent of
the patients who are diagnosed with
cancer in a given year so we've worked
very hard over the past four years since
my local cancer hospital has been open
to specifically focus on how do we bring
more clinical trials to patients how do
we get patients to be able to enroll in
clinical trials which are asking
important questions about their cancer
and are giving patients hope I think we
need more effort on the on the approach
to a patient's mood and n state of mind
with cancer and so Yale Cancer Center
and Yale New Haven Hospital and smile o
are investing a psychiatric Oncology
Program creating a cycle Oncology
Program for smile where we bring in a
team of Psychiatrists or focused
intensely from cancer and how our mood
be a depression and anxiety be admitted
depressive illness how that impacts our
understanding of cancer and our
experience of cancer so I think these
are all areas that will be important on
the clinical side for Yale Cancer Center
as we move forward on the research side
I think we need to continue to see more
efforts in cancer genetics and more
infants and cancer tumor immunology
personally I would like to see us be
able to begin to start seeing some of
the laboratory advances start to impact
survivors in cancer we've got some hints
now that some of these treatments are
able to make people live longer and my
hope over the next five years is that we
start seeing some of these treatments
applied to patients in a way that
increases the lifespan of patients who
are facing cancer and I think that in
certain here is we're close to doing
that we've done it in breast cancer if
you look at some of the big successes
over the past five years before this in
breast cancer they've come from taking
drugs which work well in patients who
have advanced disease and it actually
increase the cure rate of patients who
got earlier disease I'd like to see more
of that happen for more solid tumors
when we open the spinal cancer hospital
Joel smilow spoke to the audience who
was there that day and Joel said one of
the things he really hopes for is that
one day someone will go to his
granddaughter his granddaughter is with
us in the audience and she was about 12
years old at the time and some will go
to your grant his granddaughter and say
you know we've got this problem your
grandfather gave the smile of cancer
hospital to Yale into the people of
Connecticut for the express purpose of
taking care of cancer and say to his
granddaughter we've now cured cancer
what should we do at the hospital now so
I would very much like to see that
happen as well and I think that that's
something which is a dream and a vision
which is within our scope but I also
think it's important to know that these
things do take time and I just don't
know how soon that will be is it is it
10 years is it 50 years is it a hundred
years I do think it's going to happen
but I just a not certain as to the pace
of which is going to happen and so
within my career I don't see a time
where I'm going to feel satisfied that
we've done the job I think it's going to
be something that's going to need to
continue